I'm Abbie Brown I teach at Torrey Pines
High School in San Diego
I've brought four of my students with us
here to the Wolfram conference to
present this year I'm Eric Nelson
founder and CEO of augment and we are
presenting high school teaching and
programming training with Mathematica
I'm here with Eric Nelson from augment
software along with four of my students
we have Joseph Kuo who's currently a
student at the University of Illinois
here in Champaign Alex Krotz who's
attending Cal Tech and Kevin Lynn and
Shishir Reddy who are seniors with me at
Torrey Pines in San Diego California and
we're all like amazed at the amazing
rain that you have here in Champaign
it's a you know those of us spoiled
weather wimps from San Diego so a little
background about me I've been a
Mathematica user since the early 90s and
I used it as a college student and then
later as a teacher as a tool to you know
create resources for my classes and
eventually I had students put together
their their own activities and
incorporate Mathematica into their
presentations in 2006 I started a class
that we called the advanced topics in
math class which is a project space
course and I've had students present
here several times in the past with some
of the work that they've done there so
some of the highlights of my experiences
with Mathematica have included working
with the Wolfram community it's been so
great to be back and see familiar faces
and strike up old conversations again
from the past I've had been able to
enjoy the flexibility of creating my own
course that's projects based and and
I'll really having the freedom to kind
of do whatever we want which I know is
very unusual in a high school setting my
students give presentations every day
it's always a joy to see what they'll
come up with and and how they share that
work and at the end of each school year
we do a big projects fair with the
students and not just my advanced topics
class but my other calculus classes as
well we call it our
open house and if any of you are in the
San Diego area in May or you know you're
looking for a reason to take a trip send
me a note and we'll have you come along
to our event it's on the 30th of May got
the date up there and we've also done
some work with client based projects
where the students reach out to people
they know or in the community to work on
projects for them and we've also been
focusing in recent years and getting
more students published on the
demonstrations website there's been a
lot of challenges and lessons learned I
tried to just pick a few here to mention
today I've learned not to get committed
to a lesson plan since the technology
changes
I was running version 9 when my students
were running version 10 because it takes
a month or so to get my tech guys to
update the computers in my classroom
because I don't get administrator rights
to do that and all of a sudden these
entity things start popping up and I
have no idea what that means or I've
created an assignment that I think it's
a really interesting little graphics
challenge to find a way to draw number
lines by creating their own function
they were all done in 30 seconds because
they found number line plot that I
didn't even know existed the technology
logistics within a school district are
difficult like I said it can take maybe
a month for me to get updated who did
this school year I had I finally
scheduled the guy to come in and update
the computers and my cart in my
classroom he wheeled them out the door I
went to my desk to check email
wolfram has now released eleven point
0.1 yeah that's not happening anytime
soon for me convincing my colleagues to
use Mathematica a lot of them just look
at it as like this is an intimidating
programming thing I've been very excited
to see a lot of the additional entry
points that well for me searches put
together into Mathematica here at the
conference I want to explore those some
more but then I have teachers who want
to learn and they really just don't have
time to learn when we're in the
classroom and dealing with new
curriculum and a lot of things going on
it's it's difficult to find that time to
really get in so that's something I want
to work on some more and making
connections for my students in the real
world and finding real-world
applications because my real world is a
high school classroom so
oh I find ways to make it relevant to
students a little a little less than a
year ago I got this phone call from Eric
Nelson this guy in Minnesota interested
in working with students in high schools
and using Mathematica and he had found
me on the Internet and he told me that
he does programmer training using
Mathematica and now he's been working
with some of my students and I've had
the pleasure of watching them blend the
skills that they have learned in my
classes with things that they have
learned through augment so the students
who are here today are going to be
sharing some of their work and some of
their process with you that they have
developed through augments so I'm gonna
turn it over to Joseph who's gonna talk
about some of his experiences hi I'm
Joseph and I'm here I'm here as a
student from the University of Illinois
and last year I worked on a project I
was part of a pilot group and so we
developed game and we developed a game
because games are fun but and also
they're intriguing but more importantly
it provides us a single context to learn
a whole bunch of concepts and so the
most important thing that I got out of
this was the importance of documentation
and as you can see here we have our
designers intent and our pseudocode and
our code is well commented and what this
allows us to do is it allows us to
collaborate much better and therefore
we're allowed to develop specialties in
which we called a jigsaw team which each
individual is allowed to go narrow and
far into one small thing
and so by collabora we can create
something much greater and so so I'm
gonna demo the game we created a game we
call it the birdbrain game and this is
supposed to assess the intelligence of
birds and in our case we adapted it for
humans and so when we run the game it
creates a list of colors so in our case
the first one is blue then it's green
then black and so that
the planar cycles through the training
session and during the training session
the player knows that the one on the
right is greater than the one on the
left so as you can see a blue is I mean
I yellow is after blue and so that after
going through all these pairs they will
eventually figure out this list and when
they begin testing they'll be presented
with two colors and they have to
identify which if these are in the
correct order which this one in the case
is and I'm going to show you what
happens if we get it wrong which I'm
going to say that this one is true and
so as you can see it shows that that
sometimes you can be right sometimes you
can be wrong and so more importantly
birdbrain game can be used as a model to
assess intelligence and we can test our
theories that we have about it for
example one theory that we might have is
that birds might be better at memorizing
lists than humans are and so that we can
test this theory and so I'm gonna hand
this over to Alex who's gonna talk more
about models take away Alex Thank You
Joseph
hi my name is Alex cross I'm a student
at Caltech and I want to talk to you for
a little bit about the models Joseph
brought up and talk about the role in
the educational process using models in
education isn't a new idea it builds
largely off the ideas of JW Forrester at
MIT who pioneered the area of systems
dynamics and towards the later parts of
his career spoke heavily on the use of
computer simulations in learn in the
learning process we all develop internal
models whether we do it consciously or
subconsciously
when you wake up in the morning you see
the Sun if one day you were to wake up
and see the moon you'd know that's
something we're very very wrong
similarly you all develop certain
intuitions about your respective fields
of study sorry let me you'll develop
intuitions about your respective fields
of study and that's the foundation of
your internal model that's been
validated over years and years of
experience in the field
so when we're confronted with something
that violates our internal model we have
two choices we can either reject the
outside source of data say it's bad data
or we can change our internal model and
it's this changing to our internal model
that is fundamentally what learning is
when we learn we're really modifying our
internal interpretation of things and
adapting it to a wider set of variables
and so that's where this idea of non
intuitive concepts comes from when we
have something where we can't fit it
into our model or we're struggling to
change our model in a way that fits
previous experience and current
experience its so-called not intuitive
so the best way to edit a model is to
externalize it to turn it into something
tangible something that we can read line
by line and scrutinize and that's where
Mathematica comes in we can use
Mathematica to externalize our internal
models make edits to them simulate these
edits see what effect they have in real
time in front of our eyes and then
internalize them and by the end of the
development of a model we're in a much
better position to modify our internal
understanding of a subject so I want to
turn your attention to this demo I poses
a question about the position of a
rocket with respect to time and gives
you some input about the mass of the
rocket etc so you can see on the right
or sorry on the left there's a student
with a rather naive understanding of
physics who would be able to tell you
they can solve this problem using
Newton's second law force equals mass
times acceleration drive get the
acceleration then integrate twice to get
the position with respect to time but we
know that's not correct because Rockets
don't have a constant mass as they you
know burn their fuel so when we expose a
student to this idea that the mass of a
rocket is not in constant they're able
to take it and interpret it into a new
model one that takes this function M of
T and interprets it into newton's second
law and they come up with Newton's
second law for variable mass which as
you can see has a totally different
result and it's this movement from
initial model that shows a naive
understanding to a further model that
shows less naive understanding that is
fundamentally what learning is they
would then be able to take perhaps after
they learn differential equations and
conservation of momentum they'd be able
to actually derive the real
rocket equation which we use to predict
the path of rockets I want to leave you
with one idea to think about and that is
that we can now use Mathematica to
simulate pretty much every high school
class and most of the classes taught at
the undergraduate level and yet we don't
use Mathematica even at the elementary
and middle school levels even though
that's where the fundamental
understanding of these physical systems
has to come into place if you can get a
young student to understand how should a
physical system behave before they ever
have to prove it with equations or
derivation then they'd be in a much
better position to learn high-level
physics and math concepts in high school
and so to discuss more about how these
models can be used in the real world for
business applications I'd like to
introduce Kevin Lin hello I'm Kevin
alright so this will this is one of the
models she's here and I worked on a
tournament alright let's make it a bit
bigger okay so what's your name Nick all
right so what a shame alright so you're
a day of scientists well now you have
the honor of being a CEO so now you're
our CEO so Nick if we can't just use a
small the first thing you look at is
this chart right here and so what this
chart says is it tells you the top five
factors that will influence employees
decision to either stay in the actually
color code zone so green means that the
employee will stay in revenues employee
will leave and so this is really useful
as CEO because then you can just see
like what factors watch me like impact
them something that is also really
unique about the smell is else takes
occupation position into account so you
have your research scientist you have
your developers and so if you go here
and you go to the plot it will actually
take into account your job role because
as you know different job roles have
different amounts of money in people
stay for the money
most of time and so now you can see for
example an employee named Sophie and she
was day assigned she's a research
scientist you will be able to see how
employee
okay and so if you want to go more into
depth you go your bubble chart and so
some yeah it seems really intuitive is
the years you see other company so when
you just get you company you might be
wishy-washy if you like sure you stay
sure you leave and so all reflects this
because at the tree after the three-year
mark you know the amount of fish in
rates actually drops significantly as
you can see there's a nice big dip it's
after that V your mark you can actually
optimize your work environment for your
employees after that and take Croatian
or they can stay longer so therefore I
should put more consideration on them
and so this is really intuitive but
something that might not seem intuitive
first is the distance from home so if
you look here you might think that the
distance from home is a standard
one-to-one linear relationship the
further you are the more like you've got
to leave but this activemodel re doesn't
really show that the variance increases
which is like the distribution of points
but there's actually no we're
relationship that can be found which
also after some thinking also makes
sense because you have the loyal
employees who will go to your company no
matter how much how far they are they
are away from the company and so this
will also take into consideration some
employment ality it's not shiro discuss
the more technical aspect of small
alright thank you Kevin
so as you can see we use predictive
modeling to extend math into business
and help businesses better understand
their employees but how does it actually
work so we took a sample data set from
IBM analytics containing different
employee profiles and these profiles
contain different factors such as a
distance and employee lives from home
while they're not they worked overtime
and so forth and essentially we use
logistic regression to find correlations
between these factors and employee
attrition or whether or not the employee
stays or leaves the company so
Mathematica handled the calculation
aspect for us what the handy function
called
logit model fit which returns a useful
equation containing all the correlations
that we need and essentially we simply
use this logic model function to also
give us statistical information that
Kevin then displayed a three
formatting it into the most important
fact most impactful factors table as you
can see here so Mathematica handled a
calculations aspect and we focus on the
data manipulation fitting our dataset
into the logic model fit function the
visualization aspects UI and
documentation and as for how we did it
as high schoolers we received training
from Miss Brown who introduced us to
Mathematica and is still training us
today and we also learned from Eric at
augment who will now explain the
mentality behind augments training
process and augment itself thanks for
sure I'm Eric Nelson founder of augment
really proud to say that I've had a hand
in training these four gentlemen and and
many of their compatriots in Torrey
Pines high school and other schools in
Minnesota and other colleges as well as
we expand here and I'm honored to share
the stage with Abby Brown who has
dedicated a significant portion of her
of her career to using Mathematica to
teach math in the high school augments
vision so I can pull this up here is
scaleable programmer training to
expertise and we are building a
nationally distributed network of
programmers at all developmental stages
novice to expert to reasons we're doing
this reason number one is we need
greater programmer expertise to meet the
software demand of today and the growing
software demand of tomorrow and as David
Parnas has said it's not a quantity
problem it's a quality problem one bad
programmer can easily create two new
jobs every year second we need to
cultivate engineering capability in
young people and we need to help them to
adopt the superior problem-solving
technologies which will dramatically
expand their horizons well into the
future versus other technologies that
are a bit more limiting so naturally we
chose wolfram mathematica as our
training language there are many reasons
for doing that it's a high-level
language it's transfers many concepts
from math and
you reduce the cognitive load because
they're already familiar with these
ideas there are a lot of reasons I would
like to illustrate it with an analogy so
for us to learn programming using a 3gl
for example like C++ we spend a lot of
time at the lower level algorithm
development and we spend a lot of time
like this guy on the Left working at the
code level we don't want to do that
especially not at the beginning we want
to spend as much time as we can at the
design level like these guys on the
right this changes the level of problem
that we can address relatively early in
a learner's training path so we're not
just gobbling roads together we're
building a system we're building upon
the the best ideas of software
engineering and pedagogy that we can
find and a lot of good work has been
done Mary Shaw David Parnas particularly
in software engineering and then there
are other domains here engineering
principles and practice has formed the
baseline skill set of new trainees that
augment here's just one quick example
and Joseph talked about this in his
section our trainees very quickly form
the habit of properly documenting their
code and that means communicating their
designers intention which is where they
externalize their mental models as alex
is talking about of the problem domain
and the solution domain and the
components that make those up and how
those components relate to one another
and this externalization makes it easier
than for someone else to come along and
pick up where they left off and it of
course also shows them what they don't
understand
and as alex was informing us when we are
when we are presented with an error or
just a hole in our mental model then we
can respond and so this is what we would
call an internal assessment of our
understanding this is actually a study
by brighter and scared a million
surpassing ourselves
this is how experts learn there learn to
address new problems in their domain
they assess the new problem based on
their understanding of that domain and
when they find holes or errors then they
address them and they correct their
model versus fitting the problem to the
model that they already have through a
continuous examination of their mental
models they are continuously and
subconsciously assessing their own
understanding now the real power of our
training however is in the team and so
the question is how do you externalise
those mental models how do you as one
team member understand the capabilities
of another team member such that you are
able to pass a task that matches their
competencies and so we've spent a lot of
time also working on assessment
specifically what is called behaviorally
anchored self-assessment and the idea
here is that there are certain
inferential indicators that you can
identify within your own behavior set
when you approach a problem a certain
way or when you code a certain way you
are able to identify signature patterns
which are able to place you at a certain
level or developmental stage in in your
programming capability novice to expert
this continuous merging of trainees into
a production system is how we intend to
economically scale programmer training
such that the more advanced programmers
are able to confidently hand off lower
skill tasks because they have insight
into the the new people entering into
the production system and they do not
lose robustness in their production okay
now these students showed you one way we
might quickly scale up in high school in
college the idea is that we need to get
this into the schools we need to get
this technology set and these
capabilities into students hands and the
way we do it is by developing models and
simulations to support
courses as Alex mentioned Jay Forrester
spent a very long time working on this
and he's still working out actually in
his 90s I believe and we believe that we
can through this network of well trained
programmers we can develop a wide
variety of high school and college
course supporting simulations birdbrain
game for example might support a study
on human cognition in comparison to say
animal cognition and we might be able to
as Joseph was saying test our hypotheses
and acquire a narrow and deep insightful
understanding of the the nature of human
and animal cognition the simulations
ultimately are designed to hook the
curiosity and gradually cultivate deep
insightful understanding of the domain
now if you extend this over time and you
have a jigsaw production team of
qualified trainees turned apprentices
working then alongside professional
programmers and mentors then you're able
to provide economical services to local
businesses and you can you can imagine
it's not hard to imagine actually
serving local small business with big
data analytics what-if simulations other
math based software services and
something I'm particularly interested in
is servicing manufacturers and giving
rise to what is being called the
industrial Internet of Things in other
words developing flexible manufacturing
processes which can adapt to varying
conditions without human intervention
any case I'm not concerned that we'll
run out of ideas for how to apply our
software engineering capability now we
do appreciate your attention we're glad
to follow up by email afterwards thank
you very much and the emails
you